le nouveau chef du bloc est avec moi me
suis dit c'est bon soir bonsoir
je me suis dit c'est pour vous a posé
cette question à plusieurs reprises
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi cette
question tous les québécois se pose et
certains ont dit mais peut-être qu'il ya
un esprit de revanche après cette
défaite en 2011 est ce que vous voulez
pas vous racheter face à l'histoire
non ça c'est ça m'habite pas du tout je
veux pas la revanche a fait pas partie
de mes préoccupations
on est en démocratie ses adversaires
sont pas des ennemis
la démocratie c'est le choix que les
électeurs les citoyens citoyennes fond
on a beau racheter face à dire je dois
me racheter non plus j'ai pour moi
devant moi une tâche à réaliser
monsieur boli venu je m'attendais pas à
ça de mardi passé on avait prévu de
dîner ensemble et ça donnait presse le
lendemain de la mort jacques parizeau
disait notre vu se multiplier
il m'a dit bon bain voici
le bloc est en santé en termes d'
association est le seul à avoir des
associations partout de l'argent il n'y
a pas de dette
on avait plus de vingt éléments mais ça
ne veut pas on a besoin de toi je pose i
would sur la situation
oui mais ça vous savez j'ai vu des
situations difficiles dans d'autres
partis que j'ai remonté vite leur
élection je lui ai vécu sa partie demain
une telle chose je pense que le sens des
responsabilités je suis dit il faut
faire quelque chose on me le demande je
n'ai parlé que ma conjointe ua les
enfants alix il est midi des amis de
pierre karl péladeau samedi dernier et
dont j'ai rappelé mario en dix ans
d'abord c'est un geste qu'on va jouer
d'abnégation de sa part et oui je suis
prêt à y aller et je suis prêt parce que
bonjour paresse québec soit un pays
parce que je veux que le québec une voix
à ottawa
je pars contre le canada moi je n'ai pas
d'esprit revanchard le japon le canada
junior
les anglais mais est ce que les
québécois n'ont pas déjà porter un
jugement sur le bloc en 2011 qu'est ce
qui serait différent aujourd'hui
imaginez vous que les québécois portent
un jugement selon npd pendant des
décennies et c était différent
ils ont porté un jugement c'est vrais
conservateurs qui sont tombées à deux
ils ont porté un jugement sur les
libéraux qui est au pouvoir pendant la
plupart du siècle précédent et ils ont
arraché aux données aux élections est ce
que tous ceux qui auraient eu des
défaites qui ont reçu de tels jeux juin
se sont aussi on la barguelonne on se
bat non mais pourquoi ça c'est vrai pour
les fédéralistes de continuer et que
pour nous parce qu'il ya eu une fois un
juge m'a serré on devrait abandonner
mais le lcd semble bien installée là au
québec sont six au sondage mais le
québec semblait bien installée au québec
sont fiés aux vendanges c'est ça la
démocratie
assez de travail à faire il faut le
faire il faut savez combien de personnes
nous parle de proportionnelle
le proportionnel la proportionnelle
c'est quoi fondamentalement ces deux
délégués des hommes des femmes qui vont
parler en notre nom parce qu'ils
partagent nos idées nos valeurs nos
intérêts nos principes
il ya des souverainistes au québec est
ce qu'ils peuvent se retrouver bien
représentés par des fédéralistes et
c'est une option démocratique la jeune
holly postulat mais comme une
contradiction la haye ce qui lui importe
pas que le québec ait des gens qui à
tout moment prennent l'intérêt du québec
et parle du projet du québec pourquoi
les fédéralistes pourrait parler eux de
ce beau pays qu'est le canapé que nous
on pourrait pas parler de ce beau pays
que pour être le québec
mais qu'est ce que vous allez leur dire
aux électeurs du québec qui estime que
le gouvernement a peu a fait son temps
parce que là le votant pour vous ils
peuvent vous n'êtes pas un parti de
pouvoir alors pourquoi ils voteraient
pour le bloc s'ils veulent se
débarrasser du oui justement la dernière
fois c'est le discours de jack layton et
pour la première fois après de majorité
et depuis on parle à peu près pas du
québec à la chambre est quand même bon
résultat c'était ça le résultat donjon
propos nié les faits que lui une avancée
c'est ça le résultat
alors moi je me dis nous on va s'occuper
de vin ici plein pedic les libéraux
faisons notre travail dans le reste du
canada les trucs de compter sur le
québec pour tenter de se donner une
nouveau au canada justement permettre
peut-être conservateur de de se faufiler
en divisant le vote entre les libéraux
et si on divise dans l'eau il y en a
d'autres que je suis avec nous
pourtant vous y croyez vous croyez que
c'est quoi c'est cette fois ci pourquoi
eux pourraient utiliser et nous on
pourrait pas diviser je recherche la
réponse la récession se présente déjà
comme un succès on retravaille est plus
à employer très fort je peux juste
toujours refusé un
en politique je n'ai fait un peu pas mal
longtemps de dire d'avant ce voleur
convient ça je ne veux pas faire ça je
veux travailler très concrètement lui
fort de mes capacités et que la
conviction qui est qui et qui est la
mienne et avec une équipe renouvelée de
jeunes beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
candidates et candidats
il faut redonner qui revient au médecin
et des anciens chefs qui sont venus
parce que il faut toujours être à la
hauteur de ses convictions c'est ce que
l'évêque fait après deux échecs ce que
mucha sera passé ce jean charest a fait
puisque jose sharks
ils ont été à la hauteur de conviction
on l'a reconnu pour eux je veux faire
comme un merci merci